[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock a big development concerning
prince andrew this morning and a first
look at his denials contained in legal
papers plus fresh pressure on the prime
minister as he waits for the sue grey
report after a whistleblower's claims on
the evacuation of animals from
afghanistan will speak to the work and
pension secretary to raise coffee it is
thursday the 27th of january
revealed the documents from prince
andrews lawyers responding to claims of
sex assault allegations as he asked for
a jury trial
but
i put her on mac
okay there's melina and she is as you
can see at windsor she'll have the
latest selling their kidneys to feed
themselves our special correspondent
alex crawford investigates the
humanitarian crisis in afghanistan
more revelations about the evacuation of
animals from afghanistan as pressure on
the pm grows we'll analyze that
police reveal the shocking kidnapping
video showing the moment a teenager
is kidnapped by her former boyfriend
what happened next was even more tragic
slice of normality returns we get
reaction from businesses as coveted
restrictions left in england
i'm in the ukrainian capital cave as uh
sky news understands that the uk could
be sending hundreds more troops to
bolster nato's eastern flank
in eastern europe
also on the program for you this morning
[Music]
and perhaps goodbye reports that adele
won't now play a single show in vegas
after postponing her residency
[Music]
and feel the rhythm feel the rhyme at 8
45. it's bobsled time we'll speak to the
jamaican bobsleigh team so committed to
their sport they did this to train about
how their winter olympic dream was
nearly thrown off track
[Music]
good morning everybody the big breaking
news you're waking up to this morning
it's about prince andrew and we've got
the first proper glimpse of his denials
about sex assault claims made by
virginia dufrey
legal documents setting out the prince's
response to the sexual assault case
reveal his formal denials
prince andrew is asking for a trial by
jury then in response to the claim mr
frey was forced to have sex with prince
andrew the document says prince andrew
lacks sufficient information to admit or
deny the allegations in paragraph 27 of
the complaint pertaining to the alleged
abuse of duffray at the hands of epstein
and denies the remaining allegations
contained in this paragraph
in response to paragraph 38 of the
original complaint which refers to the
photograph shown here the document says
prince andrew lacks sufficient
information to admit or deny the
allegations contained in paragraph 38 of
the complaint
and in paragraph 53 of the original
complaint it's claimed that after andrew
had been accused of sexually assaulting
dufres he emailed jillian maxwell
stating let me know when we can talk got
some specific questions to ask you about
virginia roberts
in response to this the document from
andrew's lawyers once again states that
he lacks sufficient information to admit
or deny the allegations we're going to
be going to windsor throughout the
course of the programme today um
standing by for us and she'll update us
very shortly before that though let's
bring in um the government minister this
morning to raise coffee of course the
secretary of state for work and pensions
hello good morning it's lovely to see
you thanks for coming in um let's just
get sue great out the way quickly when
will we get the report i don't know
i'm conscious that the uh
for su grey to um finalize her report uh
you will probably know quicker than i
will do okay but it's important that uh
that be allowed to continue as indeed
the pm said about the police
investigation and it's being it's being
held up her end but we don't we don't
have a sense of why that is i really
don't know i know that uh
the government's committed to publishing
the full findings of the report uh and
that uh but the timing i absolutely have
no idea about okay did you ever go to
any parties at downing street
i'm not aware of any parties at downing
street but it's important that sue
gray's report is allowed to be published
in the pm uh sorry the police be allowed
to the investigation
i'm not aware of any parties i go to the
county street regularly things like
talking about jobs uh like discussing
things like the way to into work uh
campaign that we're launching today
we're gonna be talking about that in
more detail but did you ever go to any
parties at dining street have i ever
been to any parties in downing streets
the last party i recall going to town
street was the celebration of when the
uk left the european union following the
referendum and that was uh because boris
got brexit done and uh he will continue
to deliver yeah was there okay i don't
recall any cake the last cake i remember
is the one the sky news party with my
face on one of it i was literally
pictured eating my own face but there we
go so there's got to be a gag in there
somewhere hasn't that um you know we're
talking about bits of cake that he
potentially ate two years ago we're
being told that he wants to be more
statesmanlike and doesn't want to be uh
mem his memory to be of things like that
as far as the public is concerned yet he
intervenes airlifting animals out of
afghanistan what do you do that for well
the pm has been clear that he had no
individual decisions on all those
individual elements of operations you
know as ben wallace the defense
secretary has said it was a military
operation ben was in charge as defence
secretary and i'm conscious that
absolutely people were absolutely
prioritized you know our brave armed
forces
worked really hard to get 15 000 british
nationals and afghans out of kabul in
that very difficult time and they're
being rewarded for that with medals in
uh as a part of operation pizza but he's
been caught lying again because he said
that he didn't have anything to do with
it
well the pm didn't make any individual
decisions about evacuation just remind
you what he said at the time here we go
yes please i've had absolutely no
influence on any a particular case nor
would that be uh right that's not that's
not how we do things in this country
well i think he said he had no
particular influence on individual cases
like nausead and sure
things have a look at this email then
from the foreign office official reading
here we go equivalent charity now said
run by an external marine has received a
lot of publicity in the pm has just
authorized their staff and animals to be
evacuated
well the pm has been clear in what he
said the defense secretary who was in
charge of the military operation has
been clear as well uh pm didn't ask him
to do anything like that you know i'll
be open with you there's quite a lot of
people will often claim the role of the
pm and supporting their stuff and
animals to be there a lot of people will
claim that the pm's involved in
supporting their particular pet projects
uh but the pm said he wasn't involved in
individual decisions that's what the
defense secretary he was in charge of
operation pitting overall has said as
well and i think it's important the
defense secretary uh is absolutely right
he prioritized people
and we were successful in getting
thousands of people out it was just
before the end of the evacuation of as
many people and animals as we could it
had to be authorized either by a cabinet
secretary or by the prime minister well
the defense sector all over it the
defense secretary um is clear that he
was in charge of the operation and the
pm did not ask him to do that also the
pm's uh i think spokesperson is saying
he was not involved in any individual
decisions
and i'm absolutely confident that ben
will have done the right thing in trying
to get as many people out of afghanistan
at that time as possible dominic dyer
who is a friend
of carrie johnson
said to lbc actually yesterday um that
the charity had lobbied all the
ministers about the charter flight as
well as the pm's wife um and
he had hoped that the pm's wife would
speak to the prime minister uh to that
end trudy harrison an mp and aid to the
pm trying to charter a flight on the
25th of august saying the boss wants
them to get out
well a lot of people will have been
lobbied i recall the extensive number of
emails i had as well at the time and i'm
conscious uh as i say the there was
i can't recall how many emails i
received uh but there was a lot of uh
concern at the time about what was
happening but the pm did not get
involved in individual evacuation
decisions
and ben wallace
ben wallace also was saying that as
defense secretary yesterday okay i
there's nobody more than me like is an
animal lover i absolutely love animals
but i would not prioritize animals over
people you are absolutely confident that
the prime minister didn't do that i'm
absolutely confident despite all the
evidence to the country well i'm the
evidence is clear also from the defense
secretary who's spoken on this at length
in the last i think 24 48 hours okay 183
people died in a suicide bomb attack
those who had supported britain for 20
years were left behind only the pm and a
government minister could make things
happen towards the end
we had heard from the defense secretary
who had said that it was complete
bollocks using his um
terminology to try to get them out he
did not want to prioritize pets over
people and then it all turned around
dominic dyer is saying heed lobby the
prime minister's wife to make that
happen well i've no doubt a lot of
lobbying happened as i explained i
recall as an mp just like others will
have done will have had a lot of emails
but i will say that ben wallace has been
clear uh he was in charge of operation
pitting and the um and the pm did not
ask him to do any individual uh kind of
evacuations uh and the pm has said that
as well okay someone's lying aren't they
pm doesn't have a good track record when
it comes to lying he was sat twice for
lying and he's been uh caught um telling
porkys again over partygate but you
still prepare preferred or you want my
viewers to believe that he's not lying
and and the other evidence is wrong
um i think uh i'm not just denying that
uh dominic dyer has said that people
lobbied ministers they did and then and
they are mps as well and the but i think
what goldsmiths are i think the
the situation is that uh you know the pm
is involved in a number of different uh
elements he trusts ben wallace to run
that successful evacuation uh strategy
under operation pitting and our armed
forces who were involved are going to be
rewarded with medals thanks to the
queen's permission for that but overall
you know there are a number of different
things the pm uh is doing really well
getting the big decisions on right the
success of the booster vaccine campaign
and that's why we're able to move
forward uh today the first day uh
stepping away from plan b into plan a
and i hope soon that we will continue to
learn to live with kovid and that's one
of the reasons we're stepping up uh how
we're helping people get into work
through our way to work program okay
let's go back to afghanistan and now
we've had the party political broadcast
we hear we heard that from the dispatch
box several times as well yesterday and
all of your colleagues have
recounted those facts to us uh
throughout the week 286 million pounds
have been allocated to afghanistan this
fiscal year um to try to help the people
there
145 million little over half has been
given so far why are we holding this
money back people are selling their
kidneys so they can eat
well that will be a decision on how the
foreign office will be allocating
aspects of different funds we continue
through our foreign aid budget to also
spend a lot of money through
multi-lateral agencies
that has continued extensively
and we will continue to
support not only afghanistan but
countries around the world needing our
help i mean their kidneys cut out so
that they can get some money so they can
eat
i understand why it was a and continues
to be a difficult situation for a lot of
people do remember that we've also
extended um a settlement scheme for
people to come and live in this country
people have already arrived i know
through my own department we're trying
to help them get into work as well as
the other aspects as part of operation
warm welcome so i think that we are
doing a lot to try and help people who
understandably have endured a very
difficult time when the taliban uh
looking at that do you think it's enough
well i'm conscious that around the world
uh that different uh countries will
continue to work together to try and do
what they can to help people in
afghanistan
but ultimately we are doing our bit with
our
up to 20 000 people to come into this
country
and but that's already happened and is
separate to the scheme that was in place
for people who had helped in particular
the uk government during that time what
about what we're doing at home
inflation's running at a 30-year
high i think i'm right in saying um
according to the uh joseph ranchery
foundation 27 percent of children are
living in poverty 27 my goodness me um
should we scrap the national insurance
rise
well the national insurance rise has
already been voted through by parliament
and it's an important way of making sure
initially we support the nhs but also
that longer term social care support
which we have committed to doing so i
think it's uh important to recognize i
think it's one in seven
of earners will be paying more than half
of the levy that will be generated uh so
the top 14 of earners will pay over half
of what will be collected through that
and actually six million people of the
lowest earners won't be paying anything
extra at all so there's a number of ways
that we're helping people a household
support fund
getting more people into works they'll
be better off financially
helping them and their families to make
sure that they can continue to have a
better life and also improve their
mental well-being too yeah more than a
quarter of kids
are living in poverty we're not doing
enough are we well there's a statistical
element that comes
okay with
what who defining who's in living in
poverty what's your connected poverty
the connection of poverty is in a
statistical term is about 60 percent of
median earnings compared to other people
i'm more focused on the material
deprivation aspect that's why we've also
put in place a half a billion pound
household support fund uh over winter to
particularly help but definitely the
best way to get out of poverty is for
people to be working and when a
household where both mum and dad or both
mum and mom or dad and dad are working
it's very unlikely that their children
will be in poverty and that's why i'm
focusing about getting
an extra half a million people back onto
the minister i mean i work in a food
bank on a friday and i see a lot of
people who come along and they if they
didn't come to that food bank they
wouldn't eat
i'm flagging that one of the best ways
is that they work as well some of them
have got two jobs and they still don't
earn enough money too well where you
have both parents working it's very
unlikely or it's something like three
percent uh chance of people being
poverty there's a number of things we're
doing in terms of the national living
wage will be going up from april uh also
we've already introduced something where
you keep more of your money while you're
still on in work benefits and those are
ways that we are trying to help families
as well and the best way that i can help
them is to try and make sure they get
into work okay and to that end you're
reducing benefits after people have been
looking for work from
12 weeks down to four weeks why are you
doing that that's not the case what
happens is that often when people are
especially new
into looking for work
our regime had been to
say you've got three months to find
something that's in your sector or
similar we know there's over a million
vacancies out there right now a lot of
them in key sectors so for new people
coming into the job center we can say
okay we're going to try and help you get
back into your chosen sector within a
month if you can't do it then then we're
saying to you it's important to get back
into work so we want you to take a job
of which you are capable because it's
always easier to get work once you're in
work and so going from any job to a
better job to a career process i'm
conscious that we still have well over a
million people looking for work a lot of
those have been doing that for over a
year now the longer you are out to work
the more difficult it can be to get back
so instead of the job of your choice
we're saying come on the experience you
will gain uh will be tremendous in
helping you get into work get more money
in your pocket
and not only delivering workers for the
economy
will be helping people with their
prosperity so the big change not only is
for people looking for work it's
actually about bringing employers back
into the job centres and really trying
to short-circuit the process of people
being connected being frantically a lot
of matchmaking going on uh so that we
can fill the critical uh jobs people
like the supply chain warehousing are
crying out for support yeah but as well
as the care sector as well okay multiple
sclerosis society talking this morning
saying it will cause huge amounts of
anxiety and stress well in terms of
people with different medical conditions
may not actually be being asked to look
for work and that's not part of this
this is about people who taxpayers are
paying week in week out to look for work
what we're trying to do is to accelerate
the process of getting people back into
work and filling the critical sector
vacancies which we know our economy
needs to do over a million vacancies out
there it's people can get work and we
will do be doing our bit
to make sure they get into a job okay
let me just go full circle before i let
you go prime minister yesterday at the
dispatch box said that uh it was right
that if a prime minister misled
parliament that he should step down um
you agree with that
i think what is fair to say let's just
said it well the prime minister said
what he said in this batch box it's
important to make sure that we continue
to wait for the appropriate
investigations to be underway and that's
exactly what we're doing well one of
them's completed they're arguing about
and and to that end um we've seen that
it has been given to the police our
prime minister likely to be investigated
by the police under caution my goodness
me well you know even more of the
details than i do k on that but i do
know that pms said it's right that the
police should be allowed to investigate
you know they have operational
independence and that's appropriate to
do so you believe him on that but you
also believe in that when he says that
if he's misled parliament then he should
go
i'm saying that the pm stood up and said
what he said yesterday and i was in the
chamber and i think it's fair to say we
need to wait for the investigations to
be completed the government will be
publishing the full findings of the
report but you know police have a
separate independent investigation and
it's their choice to decide what to do
what i do hope is that uh you know by
completing their investigations we'll be
able to you know get clarity exactly on
what happened and uh you know the
decisions that will still need to be
made and we are still making in running
this country whether it's about
decisions on vaccines whether it's about
the change uh into plan a and where we
go beyond including um you know things
that are operating in terms of trying to
generate jobs so that's what we keep
focused on right now while other people
complete their investigation looking for
the clarity so say all of us it's good
to see you as always thank you very much
indeed thank you minister thank you
let's return to our top story should we
know on prince andrew and see how the
papers are covering that story this
morning prince andrew's trial leads the
sun this morning their headline i'll go
to trial no sweat is of course a
reference to the duke's previous claim
that he couldn't sweat
the express labels the jury trial demand
a shock
the metro says that decision means
prince andrew has rejected the chance of
an out-of-court settlement with mr frey
that's their interpretation
luna is uh windsor castle for us this
morning hi melania thanks for uh
traveling all that way for us this
morning um it's a beautiful time of uh
day isn't it to see the castle i wonder
how the prince is feeling this morning
well judging by his latest application
to record feeling quite combative this
will really be the first time in modern
times they will see a royal being
cross-examined facing his accuser in a
trial by jury and
it is really a continuation of the
prince's quest to fight these
allegations by virginia dufrey she
alleges that she was sexually abused by
the prince more than 20 years ago when
she was just 17 these are allegations
that he had always strenuously denied in
fact he tried to just this month
dismissed this uh case which he was
unsuccessful after that the queen had
stripped him of his military honours and
the royal family had tried to distance
themselves from this scandal but the
prince perseveres in response to this
virginia duprey's lawyers have said that
this all smacks of victim blaming and
her lawyer david boys said in a
statement we look forward to confronting
prince andrew with his denials and
attempts to blame ms dufrey for her own
abuse at his deposition and at trial
it's worth mentioning that mr boyz is
one of the most fierce trial lawyers in
the u.s so this will definitely not be
an easy ride for prince andrew he does
threaten to overshadow the queen's
platinum jubilee this year okay malana
thank you
well as we were discussing with the
minister a moment ago the united nations
has warned that afghanistan is fast
becoming the world's worst humanitarian
disaster sky news has spoken to people
who have sold their kidneys to buy food
and life-saving medicines and some are
now considering even more desperate
measures like selling their children
our special correspondent is crawford
reports from herrat and a warning her
report contains pictures of abdominal
scarring from recently harvested kidneys
they've all sold their kidneys to
survive
the organ trade isn't new in afghanistan
but it's just got more desperate
every single person here is hungry
and poverty is driving already poor
people to even more extreme measures
this man tells us we've no choice we've
already sold our kidneys now we've got
to sell our children
and they're suffering terribly the
taliban takeover meant a massive cut in
aid and these are people with few
options
we've taken efforts to conceal their
identities for their own safety it's a
highly conservative society but i'm
allowed into a room with the women
[Music]
they agree to me filming their scars
some just a few months old the women
have sold their kidneys for less than
the men around fifteen hundred dollars
an organ
there's a lucrative trade with many
organs going to iran but the money is
still not enough most of these women are
still teenagers with multiple babies but
few rights
and now they're being forced to sell
their children so they all have a better
chance of survival
no one can tell me to sell my children
but we're struggling to keep them alive
she says and that's why we've thought of
selling them maybe better for them and
we get food for the others
it is a tragic situation and one they
see no quick end to
there is a lot of women there who've
sold their kidneys are now thinking
of the last option which is selling
their children too
the aid is fought over what's here is
far outweighed by the huge need
it's really very hard in afghanistan
right now she says and there are too
many people like me who don't have a
husband or a father to support them
back at the community outside herat
where whole families have already sold
their kidneys we're with the village
elder who's urgently trying to persuade
this family not to sell one of their
babies
i urge the world please don't leave us
alone he says stop this tragedy when
people are selling their children or
part of their bodies
but both parents have already sold their
kidneys they've already lost a child who
starved to death and they still have
eight little mouths to feed
i've already lost one i can't see them
all lose their lives she says at least
someone else will feed them
these are decisions no parent wants to
make
but hunger can break even a mother's
bond with her babies
alex crawford sky news
we'll get the latest reaction to the
ongoing crisis in afghanistan later this
morning i will speak to the unhcr
afghanistan spokesperson peter kessler
and the former defense minister now
chair of the defence committee tobias
elwood from 9am
cctv footage has been released showing
the moment a teenage girl was kidnapped
by her controlling former boyfriend
before she fell out of a van on a dual
carriageway
this is the moment
angel lynn was snatched from a street in
leicestershire and thrown into a silver
van
the 19 year old subsequently fell out of
the vehicle and was found by a passerby
with catastrophic injuries and remains
in hospital two years later needing
round-the-clock care for the foreseeable
future
on wednesday che boskill was found
guilty of kidnap coercive and
controlling behavior and perverting the
course of justice he was sentenced to a
total of seven and a half years in jail
his accomplice rocco sansom was handed a
21-month long sentence for kidnapper
still to come on the programme for you
as the weight continues for sue gray's
report into parties at downing street
speaking to the chair of the commons
standards committee there he is chris
bryant
that's at half past eight
[Music]
in addition to that on the programme for
you this morning
a place to mark a memorial
holocaust day will speak to israel's
ambassador to the uk
and we're going to chat to an actor
raising funds to help fellow patients
with blood cancer after being given two
months to live
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now
a 32 year old man in texas has been
charged with firearms offenses by police
investigating the hostage taking at a
synagogue earlier this month henry
williams sold a pistol to malik faisal
akram originally from blackburn two days
before the hostage taking akram was shot
dead by police at the scene
north korea has fired two suspected
short-range ballistic missiles into the
sea according to south korea's military
this is north korea's sixth round of
weapons tests this month both the u.s
and japan have condemned the move
flambe kovid rules introduced to slow
the spread of omicron in england have
now ended and the breaking news on the
bottom of your screen this morning is
that the government has eased social
care restrictions meaning unlimited
visits for care home residents
in is to return that's the latest that
we're hearing and then from today face
coverings are no longer required by law
in any public setting except for london
transport services
but public health guidance on masks
remains with advice that they should
still be worn in crowded and enclosed
spaces
for venues and events covered passes are
no longer compulsory to gain entry and
self-isolation for people who test
positive for covid will be scrapped by
the 24th of march although this date
could be brought forward here's gerard
tub
at this pizza restaurant in warwick
england's relaxation of restrictions
back to plan a is welcome
face masks are no longer compulsory but
like many hospitality settings they'll
have their own rules
the self have said that they they want
to continue wearing masks
and we're quite happy with that um the
front house staff especially
uh they're they're worried for customers
as well as for themselves
for england's big events and venues like
nightclubs the big change is covid
passes becoming voluntary again
at bar fiber in leeds the owner terry
george campaigned against them being
introduced and is now delighted so i
think the hospitality industry and
ourselves are going to see things uh
lifting a little it's going to make it
easier for people to come in
really looking forward to it i hope that
this is the last we we see a bit i hope
that things are now on the up
and then it's going to give us a boost
that we need
despite the change in rules public
health guidance in england stays the
same individuals should continue to wear
a face covering in crowded and enclosed
spaces
for the extremely vulnerable the shift
to personal responsibility is being seen
as a backwards step
outside his home in keithley acute
asthma sufferer aaron folds told me he's
been shielding almost continuously for
two years
i can't imagine there's many people that
would intentionally
hurt somebody
you know so
why
why not wear a mask
with mask wearing rules still in place
in scotland wales and northern ireland
england is now the least restricted part
of the uk
gerard sky news keithley
sky news understands the uk is
considering sending hundreds more troops
to bolster nato's flank in eastern
europe ahead of any potential russian
invasion of ukraine it comes after the
u.s rejected president putin's demand
that ukraine should be barred from
joining nato our international affairs
editor dominic waghorn is in the
ukrainian capital of kiev joins us
now i was listening to um people on the
radio this morning dominic who were in
the capital not knowing what's going to
happen next they're very concerned and
anxious
yeah they're in a state of limbo okay
caught between sort of normality
carrying on with life and the threat of
looming conflicts and they're watching
closely as to what's been happening in
moscow where america's ambassador
delivered that written reply to vladimir
putin's demands about nato ukraine and
security in eastern europe and they also
will be listening to the news that
britain's is considering sending
hundreds more troops to ukraine's
neighbors even before an invasion could
possibly happen and ben wallace the
defense secretary in berlin meeting his
german counterpart kind of summarizing
what the allies are doing and admitting
there is a sort of cross-section of
support that nato is trying to give
ukraine to ward off this threat of
russian aggression against it
we can all
assist ukraine in our own way obviously
the united kingdom has taken a view that
lethal aid
of a tactical defensive nature is
something that the ukrainians need
but we're not sitting in judgment over
other countries i think with 30 allies
there are plenty of assistances to go
around
as we said britain is considering
sending troops is sending anti-tank
missiles germany yesterday said it will
send one field hospital and five
thousand helmets and that's been
criticized by the mayor of this town
kiev vitale klitschkoff who said what
are the germans going to send next
pillows
yeah for now thanks very much indeed
dominic thank you
six young people taking legal action
against the operator of japan's stricken
fukushima nuclear plant claiming they
develop thyroid cancer after exposure to
radiation let's get more should we tom
standing by for us in beijing um hi tom
what more do we know about this
hi kay yeah i mean if you think back to
the fukushima disaster the earthquake
then the tsunami
and the meltdown of the plan that was
the worst nuclear accident since
chernobyl what happened after chernobyl
actually was that they noticed a large
number of thyroid cancer cases in
children following that and so ever
since fukushima what the authorities
there have been doing have been
screening for thyroid cancer mass
testing for thyroid cancer to see if
there's any effect now these six uh
individuals they're young adults now
they're between six and sixteen when the
disaster happens say uh they they all
develop thyroid cancer and they believe
it was due to the radiation from the
focus human link all of them had to go
surgery and they're suing uh the
electric uh company that ran the plant
for four around four million pounds now
uh the regional authorities say there's
no link between thyroid cancer and
radiation they have an established one
so far un committee said the higher
levels of thyroid
cancer might be due to this increase
screening that mass testing so they're
just looking harder and finding more
cases as a result this lawsuit will put
that to the test in the court in tokyo
but it's also just a reminder that even
more than a decade on from that disaster
its ripples are still being felt to the
present day okay thanks tom thank you
now after cancelling her vegas shows due
to covid and production issues it was
expected adele would reschedule the
dates in the coming months
[Music]
far from saying hello it looks as though
she may well be saying goodbye to
the
to the vegas strip caesar's palace the
venue is where she was supposed to be uh
performing it's now booked at the
country music star carl urban for five
shows in march and april dates
originally reserved for adele's live
shows parts of her stage sets have also
been removed from the venue casting
further doubt that fans will get to see
her rolling in the deep
on the strip this year
looking at our top stories for you on
the programme this morning prince andrew
has demanded a trial by jury in this
civil sexual assault case brought
against him by virginia dufresne he
denies all claims made against him
we have been speaking to afghans who
sold their kidneys for food and medicine
as the united nations warns of the count
the country becoming the world's worst
humanitarian disaster
and back to plan a curved restrictions
are eased in england with mandatory face
coverings dropped care home residents
will also be able to receive for
unlimited visitors from monday
well in the last half hour or so um i
was pressing the work and pension
secretary to raise coffee about
accusations that boris johnson lied over
whether he authorized the evacuations of
animals linked to the charity nazad from
afghanistan last summer despite email
evidence to the country she appeared to
back the prime minister
the pm has been clear in what he said
the defense secretary who was in charge
of the military operation has been clear
as well
pm didn't ask him to do anything like
that
you know i'll be open with you there's
quite a lot of people will often claim
the role of the pm and supporting their
stuff and animals to be there a lot of
people will claim that the pm's involved
in supporting their particular pet
projects but the pm said he wasn't
involved in individual decisions that's
what the defense secretary he was in
charge of operation pitting overall has
said as well and i think it's important
the defense secretary uh is absolutely
right he prioritized people
and we were successful in getting
thousands of people out
um so despite all the evidence tomorrow
no
yes while the prime minister's uh
conduct and integrity are being
questioned uh in the su-grey report
which we're still waiting for they're
being questioned again in this afghan
evacuation which has now come back
because
there it is in emails in black and white
between ministers offices saying the
prime minister has told us to evacuate
the animals and staff from this charity
this was at quite a late stage in the
evacuation now the prime minister and
indeed the defense secretary both denied
that yesterday and i thought it was
interesting that therese coffey said
several times that she would back the
defense secretary to do the right thing
in this situation so what went on well
she's suggesting maybe officials got the
wrong end of the stick she said people
often lobby the prime minister and maybe
it was misunderstood but i think
questions are going to continue on this
subject not least because a man called
dominic dyer an animal rights campaigner
who is friends with the prime minister
and his wife carrie has made very clear
that he asked for them to intervene and
as the foreign office whistleblower who
uh who provided these emails to mps has
said uh it must have been authorized at
a very high level okay thanks very much
indeed um tomorrow tomorrow's take at
nine o'clock looking forward to it thank
you uh mean time events are taking place
across the uk to mark holocaust memorial
day people are being encouraged to light
candles in their windows at 8pm
this evening while the prince of wales
has commissioned paintings of holocaust
survivors
joining us now is israel's ambassador to
the uk zippy joshua valley hello to you
thank you for joining us um on the
program this morning more than 70 years
have passed since the holocaust still
very much in people's memories though
isn't it
yes for us it's a very personal day like
many other jews and israelis because my
husband is a
grandson of a survivor his grandfather
samuel freiberg was a survivor from
eight different camps
one of them is auschwitz and
for my husband the holocaust was very
present in his life and
just for me uh just teaching and
educating
the young generation is probably the
biggest mission because unfortunately my
daughters will never
get to hear the witness
of samuel fiber their grand grandfather
and we need to think how the world is
going to look like without survivors
this is why i think what the secretary
of education is doing is incredibly
amazing the fact that he puts all the
emphasize about educating people about
modern anti-semitism the fact that today
2022 in london anti-semitism is still
something you can see in the streets
and this is why i think it's so
important to discuss
all all the things that are part of this
big virus that is called anti-semitism
and i totally agree with secretary nadim
sahawi that the only vaccine against
this virus is education
i did want to ask you about the um space
i mean we have seen anti-semitic attacks
in in london of late i believe there was
an incident in central london where a
gang of men um hurled anti-semitic abuse
and spat at teenagers um celebrating
hanukkah and we saw what happened in the
synagogue
in texas uh where house hostages uh were
taken um
it is still very much a live problem how
do we start to combat it
well first of all we have a strong crop
cooperation with the british government
and with the jewish community trust the
cst that this is the main
goal to make sure the jewish community
here will be safe
as a proud representative of the state
of israel i can say that israel that was
established because of the jewish
connection of 3000 years to the jewish
people to their homeland
is committed to the never again
promise
israel is the guarantee for every jew
around the world that
this crime this horrible crime will
never happen again so we are very much
committed together with the british
government to fight anti-semitism but we
can't just address the results we need
to understand the mindset that brings
anti-semitism interaction and i think
this is where we need to fight ignorance
uh some communities are so distant
because of of the time that passed from
the events that happened over 70 years
ago that they don't have even the very
basic knowledge about what happened in
the holocaust
this is why one of the most important
decisions that was made by the israeli
delegation to the u.n was made this year
to extend the fact that
holocaust denial and holocaust
um distortion is still part of you know
media social media and we want to fight
it and and i think this resolution that
was um accepted by the general assembly
of the un is very very important again
to understand you need to know the facts
you need to know what happened and you
need to know how in 2022 there is still
modern anti-semitism and
you need to to make sure that young
people will hear the witnesses i think
um one of the most amazing thing is to
see young people uh that are around
their grandparents um taking
the new modern version of
the witnesses they gave to places like
advashem the israeli center for
remembering the holocaust
the spielberg project that
steven spielberg devoted many um
many years for
making the witnesses accessible to
people so i think this is part of the
modern education for holocaust studies
and understanding that it's still part
of our society
okay thank you so much madam ambassador
for joining us this morning thank you
i appreciate it
sky news understands the uk is
considering sending hundreds more troops
to bolster nato's flank in eastern
europe ahead of any potential russian
invasion of ukraine the former british
ambassador to ukraine from 2008 to 2012
and author of the hitchhiker's guide to
diplomacy lee turner is with us now hi
thanks for joining us um on the program
this morning how concerned are you about
what russia might do next
i'm extremely concerned we're in an
extraordinarily dangerous situation
thanks to russia having positioned more
than 100 000 troops on the borders of
ukraine
with obvious potential
military intent
and it's a tinderbox and every
additional russian soldier that goes to
the border increases the risk
either that moscow will launch an
invasion because that's what it's wanted
to do all the time
or of course whenever you have this kind
of situation the risk of something going
wrong becomes greater and greater so we
are in a very dangerous situation
he spent four years as the british
ambassador to ukraine as we said in the
introduction um how is russia viewed in
ukraine
well between the peoples of russia and
ukraine there's an enormous amount of
friendship
many
families are intermarried people
from soviet era many people from russia
have lived in ukraine and vice versa
but
since
the russian
annexation of crimea and their invasion
or their supporting of separatist forces
with russian forces in the eastern
ukraine and
luhansk and donetsk regions
enormous
hostility really has grown up in ukraine
towards the russian government
and even in russia itself
very few ordinary russians really
understand why the russian leadership
seems so intent on threatening ukraine
and i don't think there's enormous
popularity in
russia
for an invasion they can't quite see why
russian soldiers should be dying in
ukraine to achieve some nebulous goal
what's the demo what is the diplomatic
route out of this
well i think the west needs to do two
things first of all
i think it's very sensible to make sure
that the ukrainian armed forces are as
well trained as possible
and have the best possible military
equipment defensive military equipment
of course in order to make any russian
invasion as difficult as possible the
one thing that we know that the russian
leadership really hates is seeing body
bags coming back to moscow and
petersburg and
we've seen in the east of ukraine and
donetsk
that the russians have gone to enormous
lengths to try and hush up
the deaths of russian military personnel
so
the military support is one angle and of
course it makes sense for nato forces to
bolster their presence in nato countries
on the borders
of the former soviet union in order to
reduce any possible risk of conflict
spilling over but in terms of diplomacy
it's absolutely vital that we keep open
the door to discussions to address what
are in some limited areas legitimate
russian concerns about security it's
true that uh napoleon did invade russia
in 1812 and
the forces of nazi germany did invade
the soviet union in 1941 and russia does
have things it could legitimately talk
about and that includes for example how
to make sure that any exercises that
either side holds are well advertised to
resist to
reduce the risk of an unnecessary
growth in tension or arms control and so
there are us
russia talks going on there are talks
going on in the minsk group
format which is ukraine
russia
germany and france and those are very
important too
so um
do you to what extent do you subscribe
to the thought mr ambassador that
put it put simply um putin is got an eye
on what's happening with china trying to
remain relevant so picking a fight with
the west
i think
putin's main motivation in all this is
domestic
the
russian economy since 2013 has shrunk by
about 40 in terms of gdp per capita so
russians feel much poorer than they did
seven or eight years ago
plus
the russian leadership is very concerned
about the fact that ukraine is
demonstrably
a much more democratic country than
russia and we can see that up until 2013
russia was quite relaxed about ukraine's
growing western orientation
but after the pro-democracy
demonstrations in moscow in 2011 to 2013
the so-called bologna protests
russian policy did a u-turn and suddenly
they started objecting to
ukraine
getting closer to the eu and they've
become much more aggressive so i do
think that the motivation of this is
primarily domestic
mr ambassador good to talk to you thank
you for joining us
thank you very much very much
astronomers in australia have spotted
something spinning through space which
is unlike anything they've ever seen
before
this is what it looks like
scientists believe that it could be the
remnants of a collapsed star with an
ultra powerful magnetic field dr natasha
hurley walker from the international
center for radio astronomy research says
the finding came as a really big
surprise
we spotted this really unusual source
and it's repeating its radio signal once
every 18 minutes
so what we think this could be is an
enormously magnetic neutron star that's
rotating and it sends out a beam of
radiation as that intersects the earth
we see it as a pulse switching on and
off
i read a statistic the other day that
said something like 60 of ufo sightings
are from people coming out of the pub
we've heard allegation after allegation
about what boris johnson may or may not
have done during lockdown it's now up to
the metropolitan police and sue gray as
to what happens next but this isn't the
first time police have investigated
downey street to talk more about it is
uh tim bell professor of politics at
queen mary university of london hello to
you professor thanks for joining us yes
so the police have been called to the
door of number 10 metaphorically
previously
they have um and the most recent and
probably the most famous case was that
of tony blair during 2007 when um the
police were concerned to try and
investigate something called the uh cash
for honours affair whereby the labour
party had supposedly um
persuaded some people to convert what
were donations into loans and therefore
didn't have to be declared to the
electoral commission
um
in exchange for being promised a seat in
the house of lords or
some other honor
the
the investigation went on for months i
think it was 14 or 16 months and tony
blair was actually interviewed during
that investigation but the important
thing to say is that he was not
interviewed under caution he was
interviewed as a witness
and very interestingly blair made it
very clear at the time that had he been
forced to be interviewed under caution
then he felt he would have to resign as
prime minister
something which i think is
pertinent and relevant to
today's case
and what difference does it make if if
the prime minister is um questioned
under caution by the police what
difference would that make for his
standing
well that indicates that the police
suspect that
the person themselves has committed a
crime rather than being
a material witness
to said crime so i think that um
suggests if you like and probably would
in the course of public opinion um that
said prime minister had uh more
questions to answer if you like
than would be the case if you've simply
been interviewed as a witness
yeah i was looking at the latest polling
um yesterday after work and the prime
minister at polling is lower now than
jeremy corbyn's was when he lost the
last election in uh 2019 have previous
leaders managed to bounce back from a
position like that
i think
it would be very difficult to bounce
back from this low base but i i should
remind people that actually boris
johnson's personal ratings have never
been that high and they've always been
very poor when it comes to honesty and
trustworthiness and yet he still won the
election by some margin
in 2019 now obviously leaders make a
difference to people's uh voting
calculus but the leader isn't the only
thing and the party's brand makes a
difference how the economy is going
makes a difference people's social and
cultural values make a difference so
there are all sorts of things that go
into the mix when people and decide who
to vote for so um simply having an
unpopular leader or having a leader
who's got problems in particular areas
doesn't necessarily condem uh a party to
defeat at that the next election but i
think those uh ratings for boris johnson
are very very worried
did he win or did corbyn lose i mean
that's a whole different discussion for
another day
but um as far as kia stammer is
concerned um up against him we saw it
yesterday um in glorious technicolor
when it was prime minister's questions
he's a much more softly spoken man um
looking back in history we like our
leaders to be charismatic don't we did i
read somewhere that uh politics is show
business for ugly people
yeah you did but um
some uh other regularities have to be
observed and that is when um parties uh
decide on a new leader which of course
may still happen although boris johnson
did supposedly very well at pmq's
yesterday conservative mps may still
after the supreme report comes out
decide to mount a
vote of no confidence but when leaders
are replaced they're very often replaced
by a rather different character so for
example margaret thatcher this iconic
figure was replaced by john major who
some people saw as a rather grayer
figure
and you you can see uh examples of this
even when we look at tony blair for
example gordon brown a very different
kind of man very different kind of
politician uh replaced blair so there is
if you like this pendulum effect when
parties are picking um leaders and
although charisma matters competence
matters an awful lot and there's an
awful lot of research um from the
political science community which
suggests that although we talk about you
know the rise of social and cultural
values this realignment that we see in
uk politics actually people still value
uh competence and the idea that you know
these guys are going to do a better job
of managing the country and in
particular managing the economy than the
other guys
um fascinating stuff thank you so much
for taking the time we'll chat again i
hope thank you
um let us know your thoughts if you've
on any of the stories that we're
covering here on sky news um today you
can tweet me directly if you would like
to at scan news lots of you tweeting
already about my interview with therese
coffee if you haven't seen it check it
out on twitter quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
fine for most today but the south will
be gray and damp for a time there's more
rain heading for the north for friday
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
okay have a look at these pictures see
what you think going once going twice
not sold
here we go this is melania trump she's
found a difficulty auctioning off this
bespoke hat matching her white ensemble
the former first lady put the
one-of-a-kind hat up for sale on her
website but only managed to draw five
bids with the winning bid being 80 000
less than her minimum asking price it
thought most bidders were skeptical of
mrs trump's promise to donate a portion
of the proceeds to charity it was what
she wore when macron came to town also
john rendall who was famous for taking
his pet lion which he bought from
harrods in the 60s on adventures around
london has sadly died at the age of 76 a
lion named do you remember christian and
was a common sight walking around
chelsea and a popular guest at parties
he was returned to the wild in 1970 no
toilets in the wild for you young man um
and sadly he has died an iconic picture
that one uh still to come we are going
to be looking in more detail about what
the government has said this morning
about taking animals out of afghanistan
stay tuned for more
[Music]